- Hello, everyone.
This is the 2021 Finzi-Contini Lecture
at the Whitney Humanities Center.
I'm Paul North, the interim director.
Alice Kaplan, the current director,
will be back in the spring.
I'm thinking of a contrast
in the movie by Vittorio De Sica from 1971
called "The Garden of the Finzi-Continis."
De Sica shows the huge
generosity of spirit
of this Italian-Jewish family.
And then the shock and dismay
when they're brutally displaced
by fascists and antisemites.
A tennis court in Milan
full of young people
at the beginning of the film;
the painfully empty
tennis court at the end.
Both of those characteristics
are present each year
in this lecture named after the family,
when the family's continuing
generosity makes it possible
to hear a literary writer,
who was often writing from the thick
of current global crisis.
The Finzi-Contini lectureship
was endowed in 1990
by the Honorable Guido Calabresi,
Judge, US Court of Appeals
for the Second Circuit
and former Dean of the Yale Law School,
and by his brother, the
late Dr. Paul Calabresi.
The lecture honors their
mother, grandmother
and great-grandmother, speaking
of the family as a whole,
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini Calabresi.
She and her husband, Massimo Calabresi,
activists in the resistance
against Italian fascism,
fled Italy in 1939
after the passage of the
first infamous racial laws.
They settled in New Haven to start anew.
He as a physician, she
has a literary scholar.
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini Calabresi
earned her PhD in French at Yale in 1949,
with a dissertation on Ernest Renan.
Her subject was one of the
most fascinating writers
of the 19th century.
A liberal and a brilliant
analyst of nationalism
and Christianity, who believed
in racial hierarchies,
but nonetheless counted among his enemies
the most vicious antisemites in France.
Her thesis was directed by Henri Peyre,
a European exile from Paris
who wanted to see her appointed
to the faculty at Yale,
but the 1949 Yale Corporation refused.
There would be no tenured
women on the faculty at Yale
for another three years.
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini
Calabresi was undeterred.
She went on to become
professor of French and Italian
at Connecticut College,
and then chair of the
Department of Italian
at Albertus Magnus College.
Her last published volume,
also written in French,
was on Renan's friendship
with Emile Egger,
one of the founders of classic philology.
She died in 1982, at the age of 80.
We wish to thank Judge
Calabresi and his family
for their generosity, and
for giving us the privilege
of remembering our distinguished alumna,
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini Calabresi.
Greetings to the three
generations of Calabresis,
who are in the audience this evening.
The Finzi-Contini Lectures
sponsors a distinguished speaker
in the field of comparative
literature, broadly defined.
In 1991, the inaugural lecture was given
by the great Italian
semiotician Umberto Eco.
Subsequent lectures in
this series have been given
by a now long list of eminent
writers from around the world,
including Tzvetan Todorov, A.S. Byatt,
Orhan Pamuk, Masha Gessen, Azar Nafisi,
and Maxine Hong Kingston
among many others.
Beginning with our March
2021 Finzi-Contini Lecture,
The Yale Review has joined
the Whitney as co-sponsor.
Please look for today's talk in print,
in its pages and online.
Race Off will appear
in the fall 2021 issue
of The Yale Review
edited by Megan O'Rourke,
who we thank for all her help.
Now, let me welcome Namwali Serpell.
Professor of English at Harvard,
previously a professor
at the University of California, Berkeley,
literary critic, theorist of colonialism
and global struggles around
race and post-coloniality,
and just as importantly,
a fiction writer of note.
Her first published story "Muzungu"
was selected for The Best
American Short Stories 2009
and short listed for the 2010 Caine Prize
for African writing.
She also won the 2015 Caine
Prize for her story "The Sack."
Her first book of literary criticism
called "Seven Modes of Uncertainty"
was published by Harvard
University Press in 2014.
And our first novel, "The Old Drift"
came out with Hogarth Press in 2019,
and won accolades as diverse
as the Anisfield-Wolf
Book award for fiction
and the Arthur C. Clarke
Award for science fiction,
as well as being included
among the hundred notable books of 2019
by the New York Times
and Time Magazine's 100
Must-Read Books of the Year.
Must-read books.
About those words, must and read,
they really don't go
together, or shouldn't.
Aesthetic experience
is supposed to be free
in a way that the moral
must doesn't allow.
We can read about all sorts
of things that we should
by no means than go and do.
For Serpell, literature
is free in this way.
It, quote, enlivens and, quote, activates.
I'm quoting from "Seven
Modes of Uncertainty".
But there's a special
obligation present too.
There's a longer quote from that book.
Quote, literature produces free choice.
We have to decide what something means.
But this free choice is
forced on us by the text.
This is a line from the
scholarly and critical book
from 2014 "Seven Modes of Uncertainty,"
and you can see how she's
changing up the obligation.
As a reader, you choose
what something means freely,
but you have no choice but to choose.
So how do you do it?
The first step is to
recognize uncertainty.
Uncertainty is not primarily
an epistemic problem,
a problem with knowledge.
I don't know, or I don't
know whether I know or not,
which is bad enough.
But it's a problem that lies in, quote,
the recesses of the word ethics.
Maybe I should act, and maybe I shouldn't.
Maybe what I'm doing or plan to do
won't even count as action
in this singular and complex scenario.
When encountering a complex
scene in literature,
this is one step more difficult,
do I read a scene this way or that,
or can it be read in both ways at once?
This is the highest point of
tension for literary critics,
where they usually give up and say,
many interpretations are possible.
Serpell tarries with the tension.
We can't give up either interpretation.
Situations are by nature compound,
coming from multiple
perspectives and multiple paths
and heading toward multiple futures.
What is to be done?
This is where a reader of literature
confronts the conundrum
of ethical judgment
in a direct and unabashed way.
And this is a good thought
with which to approach "The Old Drift",
Serpell's prize-winning novel.
I quote from the Windham Campbell website,
which awarded her its
prestigious prize in 2020,
quote, "The Old Drift" tells
the story of three families,
with people of African,
European, and Indian descent,
living in Zambia over
the course of 200 years.
Part historical adventure,
part psychological realism,
part futuristic thriller,
and part magical realism,
the novel is an audacious,
lush, sprawling,
and altogether brilliant celebration
of the artifice of fiction.
It's also a laboratory
for readerly ethics.
For the beginning of the
novel, Percy M Clark,
a white European,
arrives at The Old Drift,
that part of the Zambezi River
that's not too dangerous to be crossed.
Clark is a pathetic, minor, sad
version of accessible roads,
an imperialist of the small
whose casual and unquestioned racism
and thoughtless day-to-day
brutality you can never accept,
and yet the routine hardships of his life,
losing a baby, struggling to earn enough,
fitting his meager intelligence
into the colonial hierarchies,
make the ethical judgment
harder and more pressing.
What would judging and
sentencing this colonist do?
What would it have done?
Devastation and domination happened
through a million almost
normal lives like this one,
or rather the almost normal,
as I came to feel electrically
in my bones when reading the
book, is riddled horrors.
Clark shoots a black boy
in the back with buckshot,
mistaking him for an animal in the brush.
I want to single out an
important insight here
that once the imperial project is set up,
horrors come to look
like collateral damage.
And what to do with an indirect evil
that is almost coincident with normal life
was very vocabulary collateral
damage, conceals it again.
This is the main task of
an ethics of uncertainty
and ethics of reading.
One answer is to allow our response
to let the other side speak,
which Serpell does in
addenda to each chapter,
where a pre-national,
even pre-human collective
judges from a cold,
unsympathetic distance.
The book is responded to
by a chorus of mosquitoes,
who tell us about the unconquerable parts
of the conquered space.
Parts that are too big, too hot, too wet,
that change too much,
full of uncertainties.
Quote, this is what the mosquitoes say.
"Evolution forge the entirety
of life using only one tool:
"the mistake," unquote.
As you can see,
Professor Serpell doesn't
run away from complexity,
and her project of a non-simplifying
ethical education continues.
She wants the fullest possible
description of a scene
and recognition of its singular conditions
and multiple perspectives
before anyone is allowed to say must.
I believe we're being invited
to follow her tonight,
doing something similar in her lecture,
Race Off: The Fantasy
of Race Transformation.
After the lecture,
there'll be a conversation
with Tina Post, who is
assistant professor of English
and theater and performance
at the University of Chicago
and a recent alumni of Yale,
as Professor Serpell herself is,
though, in the more distant past.
Before I present Professor Serpell,
I want to mention a couple of issues.
When you want to ask a question,
please feel free to do it.
You can put your questions
in the Q&A at any time.
Chat will be disabled,
as well hand-raising,
but you're free, as I
say, to add your questions
all the way through.
When I read the questions
at the end of the Q&A,
I will be alighting people's
names for rights reasons.
So now, without any further talk from me,
please join me in welcoming
Professor Namwali Serpell.
- Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for that wonderful
and complex introduction, Paul.
I'm going to share my screen
and launch right into my presentation,
which is called Race Off:
The Fantasy of Race Transformation,
American Race Transformation.
And it should be about 50 minutes.
What if you could change your race?
Some disturbing scandals of late
have put this hypothetical
to the reality test.
A cluster of white American
academics and activists,
many of them women it seems,
have been revealed to have spent years
cosplaying a different race.
Latinx, black, Native American,
misleading, if not outright deceiving
their colleagues and comrades.
Such deceptions are nothing new.
In the mid-19th century,
P.T. Barnum showcased
people have concocted races
such as the Circassian girl
or the Circassian beauty.
Barnum also promoted a
negro, William Cannell,
who claimed to have discovered a weed
that turns a black person white.
Newspaper at the time called
out runaway slave impostors.
At the same moment, white
writers were publishing
fake slave narratives.
And as 2017 history bunk,
Kevin Young notes that
"the hoax regularly steps
in when race rears its head,
"exactly because it too is a fake thing
"pretending to be real."
Indeed, historical evidence
and scientific consensus
both tell us that race is a social,
rather than a biological reality.
Yet we harbor a near-atavistic obsession
with the methods and
motives of race fakers.
How do they change their
skin, their hair, their voice,
their origin story, and why?
Is it minstrelsy?
Is it white guilt?
Is it fetishism?
Some have argued that being not white
has come to seem politically profitable.
Suffering is now established
as a form of cultural capital.
Today, I want to suggest to you
that these recent race fakers
are merely the latest
players in a game I call
the fantasy of American
race transformation.
If we take a lead from P.T. Barnum,
we can taxonomize this
genre along various axes:
when these texts appeared
and who produced them,
which race gets transformed
and into what race,
what mechanism catalyzes it and how,
is it imposed or
self-motivated and to what end,
is it reversible or permanent?
While there's a veritable circus
of racial chimeras to consider,
I'll train my spotlight today
on the transformations
between black and white people
and popular narrative works
created by black and white
Americans from the 1850s to now.
From passing to cross-racial reportage
to speculative fiction,
the fantasy of race transformation
cuts an electric line,
thrilling, dangerous, illuminating,
through the American popular imagination.
At first glance, there might
seem to be something radical
in the very idea of changing your race,
which assumes that race is
changeable and therefore unfixed,
in short, a construct.
But what we find is that
all the aesthetic energy
and race transformation stories
springs from the surprise
of a black person
inside a white person or vice versa,
and this, of course, assumes
an essential racial soul
lurking within the transformed body.
With this in mind, we see
that to change your race
is really just a kind
of thought experiment
geared to make you
empathize with another race,
to punish you for being bigoted,
or to grant you brief giddy
access to being another person,
a kind of racial exoticism or slumming
that lets you transcend
the suffocation of social
divisions immediately,
yet impermanently.
Race transformation tales
offer the promise of escaping the body,
but they often end up making
that body abject or an object.
In this sense, this
genre reinscribes racism
rather than rising above it.
But it does give us some insight,
not into what race actually is,
but into what we think it is.
And naturally, what we think it is
very much depends on who we mean by we.
Let me introduce you to this
race transformation circus.
The grounds are passing narratives
in which a person deemed
by law to be black
has features that pass for white.
The passing narrative first
appeared in 19th century drama
and was popularized during
the Harlem Renaissance
by writers such as James Weldon
Johnson and Nella Larsen.
Chiaroscuro, high contrast
between dark and light,
is a common aesthetic
in passing literature.
Melodramatic sentiments
of fear, taboo, desire,
and despair predominate.
It's tragic, sad, and grand.
And in passing narratives, miscegenation,
usually via the rape of
enslaved black women,
takes generations to
yield a dramatic change
in the racial appearance of a family.
Only then do we find the
melancholy tragic mulatto
distraught at the injustice
of the one-drop rule
that banishes them from full subjecthood,
torn between the white
world and the black world.
As the word passing
implies, passing is gradual.
It moves like a wave over
generations, drowning some,
wrecking others on the
reefs of guilt and grief,
and always moves in one direction,
toward the foamy crest of whiteness.
It's a lose-lose game.
Passing nearly replaces
the social death of racism
with the social death of isolation.
It trades the pain of injustice
for the loss of culture and community.
The critic, Allyson Hobbs puts it simply,
"Racial passing is an exile."
When James Weldon Johnson's
Ex-Colored Man chooses to pass,
he says, "I have sold my
birthright for a mess of pottage."
Passing literature can culminate
with not just a figurative death,
but a literal passing
over to the other side,
as in the fate of one character
in Ella Larsen's 1929 "Passing",
which has just been made into a film
that's due out next year,
directed by Rebecca Hall.
And some of you may have seen the preview
came out just yesterday.
Despite these perhaps
dark, morbid connotations,
white Americans soon wanted in on passing.
It portended greater
melancholy, greater melodrama
than the fakeries of slave impostors
and the grotesqueries of minstrelsy.
And so we come to Exhibit
A of our show for today,
race transformation as morality play.
In the 1940s, a series
of popular columns ran
in Negro Digest titled
"If I Were A Negro".
It had a famous subjunctive entry
by none other than Eleanor
Roosevelt, who averred,
"I would have moments
of great bitterness."
Over the course of the next two decades,
three white journalists
would go on to publish their accounts
of undergoing race transformation
in order to report on being
a negro from the other side.
Ray Sprigle's "In the Land
of Jim Crow" From 1949,
John Howard Griffin's
"Black Like Me" from 1961,
and Grace Halsell's
"Soul Sister" from 1969.
At the start of his passing
in reverse, as he calls it,
Sprigle first applies a
homemade concoction of iodine,
argyrol, pyrogallic acid,
potassium permanganate,
and the juice of Walnut hulls.
This just leaves him striped.
He finally realizes the
prevalence of light-skin
among the black population of the US
and opts just to get a three-week suntan
before climbing aboard a Jim Crow coach
on a train headed south.
Nothing too terrible happens to him,
which he perversely laments.
"This would be a far better story
"if I could show some
scars left by the blackjack
"of some negro-hating, small town deputy
"whom I failed to sir.
"Or a few bullet holes,
mementos of an argument
"with some trigger-happy
Atlanta motorman."
A decade later, John Howard Griffin
begins his scientific research study
of the negro in the south
by using a drug for treating vitiligo
as well as sun stains and a
sunlamp to darken his skin.
He says, "I went to look
at myself in the mirror,
"a fierce looking, bald negro
glared at me from the glass.
"He in no way resembled me.
"The transformation
was total and shocking.
"I had expected to see myself disguised,
"but this was someone else.
"I was imprisoned in the
flesh of an utter stranger.
"All traces of the John Griffin I had been
"were wiped from existence.
"Even the senses under
when to change so profound
"it filled me with distress.
"I looked into the mirror
and saw reflected nothing
"of the white John Griffin's past.
"I knew then that I was
not a disguised white man
"but a newly created negro."
The race transformation here
is like a gestalt switch
between obliteration and creation.
It is apt that the film
version of "Black Like Me"
ran as a double feature
with the horror film "The Hands of Orlac"
in which a concert pianist,
who receives a hand transplant
from a convicted killer,
descends into homicidal madness.
In both films, the physical
transformation isn't a gradual
or surface matter, but
a wholesale conversion
at an existential, even ethical level.
In Griffin's unpublished journals,
parts of which have now appeared,
one entry finds him worrying that
"the physical change
will drag along with it
"a total transformation of identity,
"even interior identity."
Griffin goes on to wonder,
if "becoming a negro
"will do some profound
damage to my humanity;
"and still more terrible,
"will perhaps forever alter
my intimate relationships."
He even goes on to imagine
having sex with his wife
while he is black,
his language teetering between
titillation and horror.
"I did not ask her if the
idea excited her equally,
"in this weird situation
"where intercourse would
be legal, morally okay,
"but give the illusion of
being a profoundly forbidden
"and even monstrous act."
Grace Halsell was mentored by Griffin
before she began the six-month
stint as a black woman
that she documented in
her book "Soul Sister",
and later published sketches
of in Ebony magazine.
Halsell takes extreme measures
with her transformation:
two corrective treatments for vitiligo,
plus a tanning spell in Mexico,
so intense that she
develops infected blisters
on her second day in Harlem.
When a black diner offers to
help her with her ailment,
she is overcome by the imbalance
of nursing between them.
It's apparently only supposed
to tilt the other way.
"I came here to know you for what you are,
"you beast, you black, black, black man!
"And you are ugly to me,
and you feel sorry for me.
"You are pitying me, you
are, Christ in heaven,
"you are loving me!
"It is not supposed to be like that!
"God, how I need you, how I want you."
Today, these putatively empathic
efforts by white writers
to understand what it is
like to be black in America
look like acts of self-serving
and voyeuristic self-victimization.
In "Black for a Day: White
Fantasies of Race and Empathy",
where Alisha Gaines talks
about these three journalists,
she notes that their "brand of empathy
"not only refuses to challenge the reality
"of black second-class citizenship,
"it actually requires it."
Gaines also cites bell
hooks' earlier analysis
of the voracious appetite of white racism,
which can turn even empathy
into, quote, eating the other.
In a world of white
supremacy, hooks writes,
"Desires for the primitive
or fantasies about the other
"can be continually exploited
"in a manner that
reinscribes the status quo."
White racial surrogacy, in
fact, relies on the assumption
that black suffering is
not legible, not real,
not worthy of redress
until it is experienced
and articulated by a white person.
As Saidiya Hartman puts it
in "Scenes of Subjection",
"Can the white witness of
the spectacle of suffering
"affirm the materiality of black sentience
"only by feeling for himself?"
The masochism of becoming black
isn't just a way to assuage white guilt;
it is also a surreptitious
way to flaunt one's ability
to survive racism, it's not
so bad if I made it out alive,
as well as one presumptive
prerogative to "Get Out",
to invoke Jordan Peele's film,
which I'll discuss later.
In short, the immediacy,
transience, and opportunism
of race transformation
encourages a self-congratulatory,
self-fulfilling return to whiteness.
In some sense, it's as
though these figures
need to go across the line
in order to consolidate
whiteness by returning to it.
These writers are, in some ways,
like the minstrel performers who,
as David Roediger writes
in "Wages of Whiteness,"
claimed the right to turn black
for as long as they desired
and to reappear as white.
These non-fiction memoirs betray a desire
for the monstrous consequences
of racial surrogacy
that still relies on being able
to escape those consequences.
The wish to expose self-evident racism
comes to look a lot like
a desire for suffering.
Halsell breathlessly anticipates
being raped by both black
men and black women.
"I went with trembling
heart to the ghetto, Harlem,
"fearful that a big black bogeyman
"might tear down the paper-thin door
"separating my white body
from his lustful desires."
Alisha Gaines notes the irony
that Halsell actually quit the project
when a white man assaulted her.
Griffin's book evolved
out of a series in the magazine Sepia,
which began with a piece
entitled Journey Into Shame,
implying, of course, a journey back out.
The pleasure and the penance
of race transformation
are intertwined.
The racist white person
secretly yearns to be whipped,
and what better way than to become black.
But as Gaines wisely notes
in her title, only for a day.
The 1986 film "Soul Man"
captures this amalgam
of resentment, guilt, and entitlement.
A white student takes tanning pills
to make himself eligible for a scholarship
for black students at Harvard Law.
He falls in love with a
really black single mom
who was, as it happens,
the runner up for the scholarship he got.
The jokes are automatic.
He plays basketball badly.
He flirts with stereotypes.
His preference in music
turns to the soulful.
He has sex with a white woman,
who exoticizes his penis.
He eventually confesses,
promises to donate to civil rights groups,
punches a couple of racists,
and is bestowed with this blessing
from his really black professor.
You've learned something I can't teach.
You've learned what it
feels like to be black.
Our penitent gets the girl,
gets to stay, gets an A minus.
One can't help but feel that,
as a minor character snarks,
this whole thing is an argument
against these affirmative
action scholarships.
The irony of the penance
arc in race transformation,
whether inflicted on
the self or on others,
is that it ends up skewing the equality
implied by race transformation
in the first place.
You might think that the upshot,
as in Dr. Seuss's "The Sneetches",
would be that the plain-belly sneetches
and the star-belly sneetches
are the same inside.
If only the plains and the stars
could understand each other,
could understand what it's like
to be in each other's skin,
everything would be fair.
But real life is haunted with hidden forms
of asymmetry and injustice,
consider the etymological
origin of the word fair.
Thus, we find the curious fact
that in all the American
race transformations
I've encountered, while
both white and black people
swap skins for pleasure or for privilege,
I found no black person ever
turned white as a punishment.
It is somehow inconceivable
that to become white
could ever be undesirable.
The obverse implication
is that to be white,
yet able to turn black at
will, is to have it all.
You get to be white, you get to be black.
And if experiencing racism humbles you,
that's all to the good
too, a moral improvement.
One of the oddities of the
stories that we've considered
in Exhibit A are that the stories
often capitalize on the
language of speculative fiction,
the Gothic, science fiction, fantasy.
Sprigle connects his memoir
to a fantastical tradition
in which the hero wants to
turn, quote, Hindu or Arab
or one of the other darker races
and goes to an old woman
and she gives him a lotion
that turns him dark for weeks or months.
He finds that being a
black man is as bewildering
as if I had been dropped on the moon,
and his fellow white soon become
a people entirely alien to me.
For Halsell, it is a
black woman's guest house
that she finds alien.
Its residents, she imagines,
have lived their lives on
one planet, so to speak,
while she has lived on another.
Playing black makes her feel
like a spook among spooks,
disembodied, a cipher floating in a void,
and a vessel for sorts for
two sorts of personalities,
two sets of eyes, two bodies.
This language emphasizes the magic
and the surrealism of race transformation,
but also as temporariness.
The spell can be broken, the charm undone,
the race transformer, the race transformer
safely returned to a
utopian no place like home
from the alien planet that they visited.
The literary critic, Taylor Evans
calls the speculative genre,
that these texts are borrowing
from, techno-passing.
"Stories that have, as
their technological novum,
"a fantastical technology
that changes one's appearance
"from phenotypically white
to phenotypically black
"or vice versa."
And with this, I present you Exhibit B,
speculative race transformation.
In an archetypal plot,
you change your race
through some fantastical
or science fictional gimmick
that either transforms your
body or transfers your soul
into a body of another race.
In these tales, melodrama and minstrelsy
are fused into a magical presto effect.
Speculative race transformation
speeds up the melancholy,
melodramatic longue
duree of racial passing.
A better term for the genre
would be racial switching.
The race transformation
is intense, immediate,
often violent.
In typical American fashion,
the fact of racial fate,
the stain or bleach that
results from miscegenation
is turned into an act of racial will.
Narrating the ability to
turn your race on or off
with the flip of a switch
tends towards certain aesthetic effects.
Chemical or electric,
catalytic or kinetic energy.
A compression of time,
whether that's through
time-travel, identity swapping,
or simultaneity, or simply
the fact of rapid change.
We also get an overturning of binaries
through slapstick and satire.
The quasi-scientific techniques
that these narratives invent
make the process of race
transformation quick, topsy-turvy,
and most importantly reversible,
both in the sense that you can undo it
and in the sense that you can
switch in either direction,
from black to white or white to black.
Classic works of speculative fiction
have often flirted with slavery.
The etymology of the word robot is rabota,
a Czech word for forced labor.
We don't have to look too far
outside the familiar cannon
to find the specific fantasy
of race transformation
in these texts either.
In one sequence of Robert Louis Stevenson,
the "Strange Case of Dr.
Jekyll and Mr. Hyde" from 1887,
the hero spends the
night carousing, as Hyde,
then takes an elixir to return
to his more respectable avatar.
But in his sleep,
he unknowingly relapses
into his deviant double
and winks to see a hand on the bedspread.
"The hand of Henry Jekyll," he reminds us,
"was professional in shape and size:
"it was large, firm, white, and calmly.
"But the hand which I now saw
"was lean, corded,
knuckly, of a dusky pallor
"and thickly shaded with
a swart growth of hair.
"It was the hand of Edward Hyde."
Hyde, throughout the novel,
is an amalgam of othernesses.
He is small, ugly, queer, dwarfish,
hardly human, ape-like, monstrous,
a juggernaut, a troglodyte, and a savage.
The phrase used for the
strange hole that Hyde,
who's name, no doubt, puns on
animal skin, has over Jekyll,
"I fell in slavery."
Witnesses see H.G. Wells' "Invisible Man"
as black, just blackness, black as my hat,
but also as a man with a pink
and white face and red eyes,
and is piebald, black
here and white there,
a kind of half-breed, whose
colors come off patchy
instead of mixing.
The invisible man thinks of
himself as a gaunt black figure,
and at one point makes this comparison.
We later learned that he is, in fact,
white with the whiteness of albinism,
a condition that facilitates
his transformation.
"One could make an animal,
a tissue, transparent.
"One could make it invisible!
"All except the pigments, I
could be invisible,' I said,
"suddenly realizing what
it meant to be an albino
"with such knowledge."
These quasi-scientific bases
for race transformation
recur in American pulp
stories of techno-passing.
Apart from albinism, we
find vitiligo or leukoderma,
a real medical condition
in which the skin loses its pigment cells,
as well as melanosis, a
real biological phenomenon
in which, as the story
"Pigments is Pigments" puts it,
"The Arctic fox, the
American varying hare,
"the ptarmigan, and other mammals
"always turn black in the
summer, being white or winter."
David H. Keller's "The Menace,"
a 1928 four-part novella
published in Amazing Stories,
pits a humble white detective named Taine
against a group of elite
power-hungry Harlemites
called The Powerful Ones.
"They were all negroes,
"banded together for the total subjection,
"and, if necessary, destruction
of the Caucasian race."
These wicked, quote, white negroes,
having determined that the difference
between the negro and the white
is mainly a matter of pigment,
invent a serum that
turns black people white.
"Our physicians inject one drop of serum
"into the child at birth
"and any tendency to develop
pigment is at once checked."
Taine uncovers the Harlemites' plot
to convert seawater into fake gold,
and their plan to
infiltrate the water supply
with a chemical powder that
will turn white people black.
Taine's success in thwarting
these elaborate plots
over the course of many, many years
seems to stem from a natural superiority,
which the story assumes.
The white negroes can never
attain true superiority
no matter their alchemy.
"Your race can change
the color of their skins
"but they cannot change
the color of their souls.
"No matter how white they may become,
"they will always remain black inside."
In the 1930 story "Dr. Immortelle",
also published in Amazing Stories,
the narrator has undergone
an experiment in immortality.
"The gradual loss of most of my own blood
"and the substitution of Caucasian blood
"through the process of transfusion."
Blood becomes a literal vehicle
for race transformation,
but also a metaphorical one for a set
of familiar eugenic assumptions
about, as the story puts it,
the "negro race being
inferior to the Caucasian."
A white love interest
in the story has, quote,
a lily-white soul, while
the formerly enslaved black,
Dr. Immortelle, has a soul
as black as my face once was.
He also has a passionate
desire for offspring
and a tendency toward inertia
all because he still retains
a drop of negroid blood in his veins.
Swapping a soul into the
body of a different race
is a device called identity transfer.
And it's a common science
fictional mechanism
for race transformation.
This is the basis for
Harry Stephen Keeler's
posthumously published "The
Man Who Changed His Skin",
which was originally written in the '30s.
In this novel, a 19th
century white Bostonian
receives a jet black pallet of oguva gum
from a homeless man.
The homeless man claims he
got it from an African tree
that sprouted from a celestial
seed planted by a meteor.
If you swallow it, he says,
your soul, spirit and mind
will slide off into the
carcass of somebody else.
The Bostonian takes the
pellet and wakes up,
like Dr. Jekyll, to an unexpected site
at the end of his sleeve.
"The hand was black as coal.
"My God, I am somebody
other than who I was."
Over time these science
fictional procedures
seem to grow more sophisticated.
Identity transfer becomes literalized
in the form of brain transplants,
as in the 1969 film "Change of Mind".
To investigate a murder,
a white lawyer's brain is placed
in the body of a black man.
The tagline asks, is he a white
man with a black man's body
or a black man with a white man's brain?
In Jess Row's 2014 novel,
"Your Face in Mine",
not just the skin, but other features too
are transformed through what's called
racial reassignment surgery,
so named to emphasize its resonance
with sexual reassignment surgery.
A man who claims to have had
racial identity dysphoria undergoes
"a series of facial surgeries,
"scalp surgeries,
body-sculpting procedures,
"and pigmentation treatments,
"transforming me from
my original appearance
"as a Caucasian-Jewish white male
"into a convincing African-American."
While the scientific techniques
for race transformation in
these texts seem to advance,
the stories remain stuck
in an old mysticism
of racial essentialism:
the idea that black and white features
carry inherent values like
beauty or intelligence.
Essentialism also gives us the feeling
that race subsists in the soul
and that people can be
born in the wrong race.
These contradictions
should be familiar to you
from American racial politics.
Race in America is somehow
both surface and depth,
construct and essence,
transmutable yet fixed,
a contingent phenomenon
with manifest effects,
a fantasy and a reality.
It's a chess game that insists
on an equal distribution
of black and white elements,
but in which white just
happens to go first.
The paradoxical sense that
some magic has bestowed
incalculable value upon
something with no intrinsic worth
is hardly strange, though.
We engage with something
that fits this description
every day: money.
Capitalism's magic
transforms coins and cash,
making them both fungible and abstract,
indices of the values of other things.
This isn't a mere analogy
between money and race.
Money gleams and rustles
throughout race transformation tales.
The "Ex-Colored Man"
who sold his birthright
when he chose to pass,
whereas a $10 gold coin
that his white father bequeathed to him.
In "The Menace", the evil Harlemites
alchemized black to
white and white to black,
but also seawater to false gold.
And in "Pigments is Pigments"
a malevolent millionaire
is turned from white to coal, ebony black,
and then from black to a
white as alabaster albino
by a biologist.
Why, because he scammed him out of money.
These stories know that,
in America, race is money.
If one race, black people,
was essentially invented
in order to be bought, sold,
used and enjoyed at will,
the desire to transform
oneself into that race,
even imaginatively,
amounts to the capitalist impulse to own.
As Toni Morrison notes
in "Playing in the Dark",
"The save population, it
could be and was assumed,
"offered itself as surrogate selves."
Black people have so long
been deemed to be property
that to put race on and take it off
becomes akin to consumerism.
This is clear when it comes to
the contemporary techno-minstrelsy
of black fishing,
which is the phenomenon of
non-black people using bronzer,
tanning, photoshop, and/or
cosmetic surgery to appear black,
especially on social media.
Now, some might claim
that this desire to cosplay another race
is an innocent form of allophilia,
an affinity for otherness
or liking people who
are different from you.
But race transformation
tales are always grounded
in familiar stereotypes,
and this begs the question
of otherness, of diversity.
In short, racial otherness
somehow always looks the same.
It is a brand you wear, so to speak.
And so we find that the value of whiteness
and race transformation tales
always seems to manifest
in abstract aspects of personhood
like safety, status, and purchasing power.
The value of blackness by
contrast has long been cast
as physical, as sensual, even bestial.
For some reason, the two
Disney animated movies
that feature black protagonists,
"The Princess and the Frog" and "Soul"
magically place both of those
protagonists inside an animal
for much of the plot.
A disconcerting number of race
transformation tales intimate
that being a black man is
correlated with having a large
and skillful penis, an erotic obsession
that is tinged with fear and resentment.
It's just as often implied
that becoming black
bestows the ability to dance,
to play or appreciate music,
and to excel at sports.
In a 2005 episode of "South Park",
Kyle has a, quote, negroplasty
to make him better at basketball.
It makes sense that in the
race transformation fantasies
I've exhibited so far,
all of which were
created by white authors,
race is seen as a kind of property,
in several senses of the word.
First, race is a bodily property,
a set of features affixed to the body
that require great labor
or the energy of magic to transform.
Second, race is assumed to be attached
to the individual subject,
to their so-called proper self,
whose relationship to the
property of land or wealth
is often determined by their race.
And third, race can be owned.
It is itself property
to be bought or sold.
It can be pegged to a
market value like gold.
It has a form of capital
that is seen as fungible and
abstract, but can be hoarded.
Speculative race transformation stories,
thus, offer evidence for the argument
that the legal scholar,
Cheryl I. Harris made in 1993.
"Whiteness, initially constructed
"as a form of racial identity,
"evolved into a form of property,
"historically and presently acknowledged
"and protected in American law.
"Following the period
of slavery and conquest,
"whiteness became the basis
of racialized privilege,
"a type of status in which
white racial identity
"provided the basis for
allocating societal benefits
"both private and public in character.
"These arrangements were
ratified and legitimated in law
"as a type of status property."
Race is not strictly arbitrary
but it has always been
subject to arbitration,
contingent on the law in America.
We can see all of these racial logics,
passing, prurients,
perversity, and property,
come together in a recent specimen
of speculative race transformation.
Matt Ruff's 2016 book "Lovecraft Country"
entwines a history of the Jim Crow 1950s
with a pulp subtext.
In a chapter called Jekyll and Hyde Park,
Ruff revisits and reverses
Robert Louis Stevenson's
race transformation scene.
A woman named Ruby, curvy and dark,
wakes in an unfamiliar bed,
on what appeared to be blood slick sheets.
In terror, she stumbled to a bathroom,
splashes water on herself,
then opens her eyes to see,
quote, "a crazed white woman's
face hovering in the dark
"just inches from her own.
"Ruby screamed.
"The white woman in the
mirror screamed with her.
"Ruby clapped her hands over her mouth;
"the white woman aped the gesture.
"The white woman: her."
The 2020 HBO adaptation of
the book "Lovecraft Country"
repeats the sequence, but
goes on to mix its messages,
adopting a radical narrative logic
that yet runs up against a
stereotyped visual logic.
Race, as in "Dr.
Immortelle", is in the blood.
In the novel, blood seeps
up under Ruby's nails
whenever she starts to slip back to black.
A white woman's blood is a key ingredient
of the elixir that transforms her.
In the show, the blood is thicker,
more literal, more gruesome.
Indeed, Ruby doesn't turn white
so much as she wears a tight
white flesh suit inside,
which she shimmies seductively,
dancing being in her blood
than seems to burst out of,
her real body being naturally curvy
and eventually rips off in
dripping strips and chunks.
To transform your race
comes to seem laborious,
perverse, grotesque, as perhaps it should;
but it also comes to seem vengeful.
In the scene I just showed you,
Ruby starts out wearing a white skin
in order to apply for a dream job,
but winds up tying up her
racist, handsy white manager
and then murdering him with a stiletto.
The white skin of
Hillary, that Ruby adopts,
is essentially a temporary
disguise that grants her access,
or perhaps permission, to
release some inner savagery,
which is here marked as black.
The contradiction at the
core of race transformation
erupts as a clash between
the show's narrative logic,
race can be swapped at will;
and its visual logic,
where blackness is violent,
whiteness is delicate.
In writing his novel, Ruff said,
he wished to redress the
troubling history of race
in genre fiction.
"One of the many forms of
exclusion African Americans faced
"was being shut out of
the popular imagination.
"For as long as genre fiction has existed,
"there have been black genre fiction fans,
"but most of the time they were
either ignored or insulted."
He says that he wanted
to give black people
"a chance to start in their
own personal weird tale.
"Of course, tales of the
supernatural are just a lot of fun.
"There's a reason African Americans
"wanted a chance to play, too."
Misha Green, the black showrunner
of the HBO adaptation concurs,
"What Matt was doing in the
book was reclaiming genre spaces
"for people who have typically
been left out of them."
These well-meaning creators
forget, or perhaps don't know,
that while black people
may have been denied
the artistic privileges
afforded to white people,
blackness has long been the
ground of American music,
film and literature.
They've always been playing too.
As Morrison writes,
"Black slavery enriched
"the country's creative possibilities.
"The result was a playground
for the imagination."
A 21st century liberal
rhetoric of inclusion
ends up centering whiteness as
a kind of historical default,
included by whom?
But it only does through an erasure
of this cultural history.
It doesn't seem to
recognize, for instance,
that black people have long
been writing their own weird
and supernatural tales.
Indeed, black writers
invented race transformation,
not just before Matt Ruff,
but before Robert Louis
Stevenson even took up his pen.
And so we come to our
final event, Exhibit C,
black speculative race transformation
Hannah Crafts' "The Bondwoman's Narrative"
has been authenticated as the first novel
written by an African American woman.
It was first published in 2002,
but was likely written in the 1850s.
It includes a highly amusing scene
in which a black enslaved woman,
herself so light-skinned
that she can pass,
tricks her putatively white mistress
into applying an Italian face powder
that briefly turns the skin black.
The powder certainly is white,
and yet it may possess
such chemical properties
as a Cajun blackness.
Indeed, "I recently saw in the newspapers
"some accounts of a chemist
"who having been jilted by a lady
"very liberal in the application
of powder to her face
"had invented as a method of revenge
"a certain kind of smelling bottles,
"of which the fumes would
suddenly blacken the whitest skin
"provided the said cosmetic
had been previously applied."
Professor Gates identified two
scientific American articles
to which Hannah Crafts
would've had access,
both of which mentioned a
white silver nitrate powder
that in the presence
of ammonia turns black.
It turns out that one of our
most important sociologists
and theorists have raised,
none other than W.E.B. Du Bois,
also drafted a race transformation tale
when he was an undergraduate
at Harvard in 1889.
The story's narrator, a kind
of hustler, tells a white man,
"After a painless operation
performed by one of my friends
"you will appear as a
negro, a full-fledged darky;
"we will then set out
through the land of the free
"and the home of the brave."
After the transformation, he's told,
your "Anglo-Saxon lips of the
pretty red pouting variety
"have gained thickness with color,
"your hair with becoming
modesty has slunk back,
"cringing, ashamed either of the owner
"or of its owner's owners,
"and your countenance which
before the application
"of prepared lampblack
was open and winning
"has suddenly become to
the last degree repulsive.
"Presto!"
The temporary transformation
exposes this white student
to the condescension and derision
of Harvard faculty, students and staff,
which presumably Dubois was
experiencing at the time.
Yet there are advantages
into this so-called
vacation tide lark until
the negro point of view.
"You step into a new and, to most people,
"entirely unknown region of the universe.
"You will be in a position
to solve in a measure
"the problems of introspection
and the fourth dimension."
In this early speculative satire,
being black offers a double consciousness,
a second site that is not only
social but seems existential.
Another barely studied
text by a black author,
there are only 22 extent
copies in the world,
is Robert Gilbert Wells'
self-published 1905
"Anthropology Applied to the
American White Man and Negro."
And this text is extraordinary.
It includes collages, and photographs,
as well as a scene of race transformation.
A formerly enslaved man
named Sam uses a potion
to turn his white former
master, Mr. Jones black.
And that the image on the left
is precisely of that moment.
"By the time he had caught his breath,
"he was out of the door
of the white man's coach
"and thrown head long into
the negro's Jim Crow car,
"mangled and bleeding.
"Sam had heard the racket
"and was watching what is commonly known
"as the white man's fun and method
"of teaching the negro his place."
After the black and Mr.
Jones is almost lynched
for trying to talk to his
white wife and family,
Sam uses fluids and liquids
to reverse the transformation.
In Charles Chesnutt story
"Mars Jeems's Nightmare",
Mars Jeems is a hard and cruel man,
monstrous trick with his hands.
The hands on his plantation
seek help from Aunt Peggy,
the conjure woman, and
she gives them a goofer
made of powdered roots.
It turns Mars Jeems black
and he winds up at his own plantation,
supposedly as payment for a gambling debt.
A poor white overseer whips
and abuses the new slave mercilessly.
When a hexed sweet potato
turns Jeems white again,
he resumed as authority as master,
but fires that racist
overseer, relaxes his rules
and ends up with a finer plantation.
So we see again the tendency
toward pedagogical pennants
for the white racist.
But the aim of the satire in these texts
is not to rest an eye for an
eye, but rather to open eyes,
make people see the world
through the polarized view
of double consciousness.
In George Schuyler's 1931
satire "Black No More",
Max Disher, fresh from sexual rejection,
from both his high yellow girlfriend
and a white woman in a nightclub,
stumbles upon the black-no-more procedure.
This device uses electrical
nutrition and glandular control
to induce and speed up vitiligo,
which, per the novel,
"absolutely removes skin pigment
"and turns a negro completely white."
Enough people use the black-no-more
that American social
hierarchy is overturned.
Leaders of black communities
and white supremacist
organizations both riot,
politicians are rousted
and institutions raised.
To be white becomes a sure sign
you were once really black.
Newborns and genealogy
charts are scrutinized
for any hint of blackness,
which becomes a matter of
descent rather than appearance.
Black-no-more soon tumbles into a jumbling
of too many shades to
keep track of or to rank.
Soon enough, a proto tanning lotion
called an Egyptienne stain
becomes a bestseller,
and the most popular tint is the Zulu tan.
An instructed juxtaposition is evident
in the production history of
the 1970 film "Watermelon Man".
In Herman Raucher's script,
a racist white insurance
salesman wakes up black.
Hysteria ensues, screams, tears, mobs.
He desperately tries to blanch
his skin with floods of milk,
soap and bleach.
His liberal wife stays level-headed.
It would serve you right
with that attitude of white supremacy.
Is it a nightmare?
Is it his sunlamp?
Is it a medical condition?
It turns out he's just black,
having grown belatedly
into his family lineage.
The black director of this
movie, Melvin Van Peebles,
who just died yesterday,
I'm so sorry to say,
insisted on two changes to the script.
One, he cast a black
actor, Godfrey Cambridge,
who is only briefly in
white phase at the start.
Two, the race transformation
isn't reversed at the end.
The screenwriter, Raucher,
originally had had the white hero wake up
and realize it was all a dream.
But in Van Peebles' cut,
the man stays black.
The denouement grows moody and somber.
White neighbors threatened,
then bribed the newly
black hero to leave town.
His wife rejects his sexual advances.
She says, I'm still liberal,
but only to a point.
And she absconds with their kids.
Eventually he starts
his own black business
and joins the black community.
The film ends with him
leading a group of black men
in a seeming embrace of black power.
The shift between the first
and the last parts of "Watermelon Man"
make the whole an uncanny,
avant-garde work of art.
We see the same medley of tone
in contemporary race transformation
tales by black artists.
In Jordan Peele's "Get Out",
white wealthy people buy black bodies
to inhabit for physical perks.
Stronger tendons, a longer life.
And for one character, a
better photographic eye,
implying that Du Bois's second-sight,
has become a commodity.
Identity transfer takes place
through the quasi-medical form
of brain transplants:
a coagula procedure,
again, invoking blood,
that starts with hypnosis,
a spoon circling the inside of a teacup,
which you would see
Peele posing with here.
This procedure then
moves to transplantation,
a partial lobotomy and replacement
with the brain of a white master.
The film literalizes double consciousness
through medicalized zombies,
who are black and white,
slave and master in one body.
In Maurice Carlos Ruffin's
2019 burlesque "We Cast a Shadow",
the racist condescension
of his white coworkers
induce as a black New Orleans businessman
to dress up like a Zulu chief
and dance to a dark tribal beat.
We learned that he is obsessed
with earning enough copper coins
to afford a new-fangled surgical procedure
called demelanization.
Not for himself, but
for his mixed race son
whose dark birthmark threatens to spread
over his entire face.
I think the recent interest
in trans racial identity
is the reason we get a very
funny documentary style skit
on Donald Glover's TV show "Atlanta."
We see an interview with a
black teenager with dark skin,
who believes he's a 35-year-old white man.
These works of race transformation
use satire to highlight
the monstrosity of racism,
especially the way that even
apparently liberal whiteness
can abruptly tip into
paternalism and worse,
horrific violence.
Like white authors,
the black authors of
race transformation tales
play with these tropes and
elaborate unfamiliar themes.
Sexual exoticism and disgust,
penis size comes up here too,
or as Ruffin's narrator puts it, quote,
the myth that all us black men
were hung like Clydesdales.
We also see rifts on the suggestion
that blackness is somehow
closer to the body,
as well as the spiritualized
notion of a racial soul.
But I also think these black author texts
offer a counter model to the
idea that race is property.
If we look at the three
features of this model,
we can see how black
author texts undo them.
For one thing, race in these stories
is not a set of fixed bodily properties.
When it comes to phenotype,
black communities in America
have always been heterogeneous,
multiple shades, shapes
and textures abound.
These stories render skin or hair
or features based conceptions
of race altogether absurd,
precisely by showing up the fact
that many white Americans
have black blood in the family
and vice versa.
And in historical terms,
the surreal one-drop rule
meant that even an enslaved
person who could pass
was barred from buying
whiteness and full freedom.
In short, race was never a property
that black people could buy or own.
We might even say the
black American cultures
came into being in resistance to property,
as a refusal of the very
idea of purchasing people
or their ways of speaking, making art
and relating to each other.
Blackness is, in the parlance of scholars
like Fred Moten, fugitive.
This is a matter of adaptation.
For cultures to survive,
they must be willing to grow and change.
They cannot be pegged to
specific properties or values.
This would constrict them or turn them
into a parody of themselves.
Indeed, when we take a Pan-African view
of black diaspora communities,
we cannot help but notice
how radically inclusive they are.
Welcoming biracial and
multi-ethnic people,
even those who had no choice
in the rate-induced attenuation
of their blackness.
Compare this to the fastidious
parsing and policing,
even in the law, of who is white
when it comes to American white politics.
So in the black conception of race,
blackness cannot belong to a
proper self, an individual.
It is always relational and communal,
because it is inclusive.
What black authored race
transformation tales know
is that personhood and race
are not fungible, but relative.
If the white theory of
race as being property
is emblematized by money,
the black theory of race as
what escapes being property
can be analogized to something else
we engage with daily: time.
Both analogies, money and time,
convey how race is at
once real and unreal.
We impose divisions and values
onto material cash and coins.
onto the invisible passage of time.
But a money metaphor for
race is flashy, fickle,
fluctuating, a spinning coin of value,
heads and tails
alternately coming to view.
A time metaphor is steady, ongoing,
and open to contingency.
A history, an oscillation, a process.
Again, I wanna emphasize,
race is not a genetic reality,
but insofar as it is an identity
or a culture with real-world consequences;
it entails time and effort.
Hence, the very different emphases
on the diversity, duration and difficulty
of race transformation in texts by authors
of distinct races.
So a story by a white author
like Keeler or Keller,
a journalistic account
by Griffin or Sprigle
can make the process of
becoming black seem easy,
or rather facile, a
matter of darkened skin,
minstrel-level dialect,
living in the hood, and so on.
But Van Peebles' "Watermelon"
slows down considerably
once the protagonist learns
that he is black for good.
He spends time, he hangs
out, he learns, he grows.
Over the years, he becomes conscious.
In "Get Out", putting
a white person's mind
inside a black person's
body is hardly sufficient
for race transformation.
Their body stay black,
and sliver of their black
consciousness remains
emerging from the sunken place
in brief emotional glimpses.
Tears, anger, and abrupt
warnings for the hero to get out.
We come to understand that
blackness isn't reducible
to the body, but is rather something
that comes from experience over time.
Something that lasts.
This is conveyed in the film
through the black hero's
literally salvific relationship
with his black best friend, Rod.
In some, speculative race transformation
tries to short circuit the
time of racial passing,
to take a shortcut to the
pleasure, pain, passion,
and perversity of race.
In so doing, it shortchanges the way
race can be an experience
of culture and community,
one that can only happen
in time, over time
and through time.
It is an experience that we
would want not to get out from,
but to move deeper into,
move gradually with,
rather than passing, rather
than reverse passing,
rather than switching between races
and rather indulge in
Barnum's taxonomic barking.
Perhaps we might treat race
as what I hope this talk has provoked,
a contingent, curious and
ongoing movement of the mind.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you very much, Namwali.
This is the place where there
would be thunderous applause
if we weren't in this Zoom strange space.
Thank you for taking us
through a truly bizarre corpus,
with unfortunately familiar
horrors lurking behind it.
So I appreciate that.
I want to encourage audience members
to put questions into the Q&A.
Anything you want to ask,
we'll try to communicate
that to our speaker.
And I want to introduce briefly Tina Post,
who's assistant professor
in the Department of English
Language and Literature.
She's on the Committee on
Theater and Performance Studies
in the Center for the Study
of Race, Politics and Culture
at the University of Chicago,
Chicago PhD here at Yale
and performance studies,
and we do miss her.
I want to point you to a monograph
that should be out very soon,
within the next year or two,
called Deadpan: The Aesthetics
of Black Inexpression.
And welcome Tina, thanks
for helping us out.
- Thank you.
- So we can run this as we all want to.
I could start with one question.
I have a lot of questions,
and I'm really happy
you came through Du Bois
and double consciousness because it seemed
what's left out in all of these accounts
is anything like the
intellectual or consciousness
of black experience.
It's as though it reminded
me of all those pictures
of Einstein or Einstein wigs,
as though you could put
that on and that was it.
But there's a whole mental experience
that goes along with it.
Does anyone make reference
to wisdom, consciousness,
intelligence as something
you would pick up
going over to the other side?
- Not going over to the black side, no.
I mean, I think Du Bois,
in this short story
which remains unpublished,
he referred to it as unprophetable,
with a misspelling of
prophet, as in the prophetic,
which I think is quite a
funny accident to make.
But he's the only one who says
that the white Harvard undergraduate
who's been transformed into a black person
is going to have access
to the fourth dimension,
which, in the kind of
general parlance of the time,
would've meant time.
So I find that quite interesting.
And actually Robert Gilbert Wells,
when he transforms his master,
or ex master, Mr. Jones
into a black man, his wife is like,
ah, you gotta change him
back, he can't handle it.
He's not like us.
He hasn't suffered to be black.
He doesn't know how to deal with this.
And he says, if he were more,
if he were stronger,
having access to blackness
wouldn't just be a way
of accessing suffering,
but would actually be a way of
expanding his consciousness.
They're engaged throughout this text
in a kind of Socratic
debate back and forth
about intellectual and social
problems facing the country.
But this transformation has meant to be
both a kind of social experiment.
Mr. Jones learns that his
own brother is probably black
and they reunite as a result
of this transformation,
but he also, Sam really thinks,
if he becomes black, he'll have access
to wisdom and knowledge.
But again, it's striking to me
that it's the black
authors who perceive this,
who perceive that becoming
black would not just be
about learning to dance better.
- Tina, I give the word over to you.
- I don't know that I have
too much to add to that,
except that it's remarkable that the one,
maybe the one thing that's so consistent
between the narrative
authored by white authors
than those of black is the
way in which they acknowledge
that blackness is this
unknown country, right?
And I think one of the things that is,
maybe implicitly remarked
upon in these narratives
is that, historically, black
people have always known
white people very, very well.
We've raised their children,
wash their clothes,
cook their meals, we know whiteness
in a way that whiteness has
never known blackness in return.
And both, the white and black
authors, it seemed to me,
did sort of allude to the,
I'm entering this unknown
territory, and truly it was.
So yeah, I guess that's
maybe the one thing I'd add.
- That's a great observation.
I think one of the ways we can see it
is if you compare these
texts to passing literature,
where there's not very much
by way of study or effort when you pass,
it's a choice that can
happen kind of seamlessly
because you know how to
live as a white person,
you just have more privileges.
And you can don't have
to read certain things,
you don't have to, whereas in these texts,
when you become black, there's
all of this tension about,
will I know how to dance
and will I know how to play basketball
and automatically give me this knowledge
or this body knowledge, and
there's all this kind of effort.
That's the way the magic and
the science fictional gimmick
is necessary in some ways,
because it can't just happen naturally
the way that it does in passing.
- Thanks, that's great.
Tina, I don't know if you
wanna open up any topics
at this point.
- I mean, I'll say a couple things
that seem interesting to me.
The whole top is wonderful, first of all.
Thank you so much.
It was fascinating and totally fruitful.
There were a couple of
thoughts that I had that,
just things that came up
to me as I was reading it
that maybe you just put on the floor.
And, of course, I have no way of knowing
if you're as familiar with
these, some of these ideas.
One is this bonkers
one-off movie from the '90s
that's maybe this historical juncture
that we may have gone down
but didn't called "Suture."
- Oh yes, I love that.
- Yeah, okay.
So the premise of this movie,
which I saw many years
ago and barely remember,
but it's a black and white
film involving twin brothers,
one of whom is white and
one of whom is black.
And not like passing black, just black.
And absolutely nothing is said about it.
And so there's no
acknowledgment that they're not,
that they don't look alike
or constant in any way.
So that was sort of one thing
I wanted to toss in this,
perhaps fruitful.
And then, what was it,
there was one other thing.
Oh, I'll save the other thing
for later if it comes up.
It's, I think, less important.
But yeah, you nodded as
though you've seen "Suture."
- Yeah, I've seen it and
I screened it actually
at a conference that I organized
at UC Berkeley on Faces,
because I was very interested
in all of these close up shots
of the face.
'Cause it's obviously also kind of troping
on H. G. Wells's "Invisible Man",
because you have this face that's,
a face is damaged and is
wrapped up in all these bandages
and it's slowly unpeeled and then,
like when the suturing
of the skin is happening
to the black face, there's all these very
kind of intense close-ups of that face.
And so I was very interested
in the extent to which
the face is the locus
of racial identity for us.
But also in the way that the
transformation of the face
is something that's presented
as an aesthetic project.
And so in my book, on faces
called "Stranger Faces,"
which was published last year,
I talked about this and
a little bit in relation
to Michael Jackson's
surgeries on his face as well.
So I was interested in that sense.
I mean, that movie is
interesting because it,
the scientific or the
science fictional trope
of race transformation isn't
happening in the diegesis,
in the narrative; it's
happening, as you say,
in the viewer, who's given
no clue as to why this is,
and so you're just constantly working
against your own assumptions
of what race looks like
as you watch the film.
- That's terrific.
Maybe I'll throw in a paranoid question.
And you were talking especially about,
those people who did kind
of ethnographic study
and did the black face and
went and wrote these books,
I couldn't help but think
of things like COINTELPRO
and other programs in which
there was infiltration
and I wondered whether there was,
if you thought there
was a kind of paranoia,
fears of uprisings and
whether these were spies.
- Oh, I wouldn't know.
I mean, Alisha Gaines's
book I relied on heavily,
"Black For a Day", and
it's a brilliant analysis.
And she went into the archives
of these three writers
and didn't seem to uncover
anything of that nature.
But what's interesting about it
is the very desire to
publish a memoir about it
and this idea that this
is kind of confessional,
it's filled with all these emotions
that have to do with shame
and prurience and taboo
suggests to me that they
definitely weren't spies
because their whole point
was exposing (mumbles)
and kind of playing off of it.
It's a very--
- That's even if they're not
good spies for the government,
there's something like a
race spy reporting back,
in the way that Tina mentioned,
to assure the white population
that the uprising is not gonna happen now.
- That's true, but what's interesting
is that at least Griffin and Halsell
published parts of their work
in black-oriented magazines,
like Ebony and Sepia.
So the audience was not
just the white community,
it was also the black community,
which feels to me like a kind of attempt
at atonement, right?
You have to know that I tried
and that it's no use to
tell my white liberal,
progressive friends that I tried.
It's I need to tell the black community
how deeply I went into this
and how I have suffered
what they have suffered.
So yeah, it's interesting.
They're double agents, I guess.
- Okay, that does bring me sort
of around to the other thing
that I was thinking of
mentioning and then I, yeah.
Jackie Sibblies Drury's
"Fairview", the play.
I don't know if you know it.
Okay, so it begins with
a conversation about,
no, just begin, but--
- Part of it.
Okay, yes, yes.
- There's a conversation about what,
if you could change your race,
who would you be and why?
That happens as this overarching narrative
over what's happening on the stage.
And then there's sort of
this everything comes apart.
And then there's a moment of
meant to be a black communion
and community, which
seems very much in keeping
with your sense of racial relation.
And yeah, it's fun, this tall,
what might be considered a sort
of confessional theater view
as like, from all the white,
usually white theater goers,
who go and review plays for newspapers.
And I think it was a fruitful
and fraught experience for many and,
but it definitely needed
to be sort of unpacked.
And I love teaching that play because yes,
there's a lot to unpack there.
But I've realized if you haven't seen it,
this is perhaps unfair,
but maybe you experienced
some of those kinds of
reviews when it was big.
- I didn't read the
reviews, but I do know,
I do know the play.
And there is a history, and
I cut this from the talk,
but in the essay I talk about,
the musical "Finian's Rainbow",
which was also turned into a film
directed by Francis Ford Coppola
in which there is a scene,
in which a racist white senator is cursed,
that's turned into a black person again
in order to force him to change his ways.
And so I think the
history within the theater
and within film is really interesting.
I didn't quite follow what the,
what is the transformation plot
that happens in "Fairview"?
- It's funny because it
isn't even actually a plot.
So the plot of the play as such,
there's sort of didactic layers to it,
but the plot of the play as such
is sort of a black family drama,
or at least it starts that way.
And as the over, the narrative,
the voices come on sort of discussing,
well, if you could change
your race, what would it be?
And then, of course, the
answers are stereotypical.
And also, there's someone
pushing against stereotypes
and as, but the action on the stage
becomes more and more stereotypical
as that extra layer of sound
is transpiring on top of it.
I hope that's a fair summary.
I haven't re-read it in
a minute, but that's,
I think that's a fair--
- (audio warps) I think that
something that I've noticed in,
one way of putting it is that slide I have
or that note that I have,
that I couldn't find any black
person being turned white
as punishment.
Whiteness is aspirational.
And the assumption that
whiteness is aspirational
is something that pervades
all of these texts.
But in the white authored
texts, it's not troubled.
It's just sort of seen as obvious
that it would be better to be white.
And this is why you have
this kind of hysteria,
the idea that white people
could be turned black
against their will, right?
But in the black authored texts,
there's very much a kind of sense that
to be made white is not
necessarily what you want
and that there's a cost.
And this is why we have this
history in passing literature
of it being presented as a kind of death.
And it's also something
that really fascinates me
just at a kind of personal level
that whenever I'm asked about the fact
that I have a white
parent, there's a kind of,
sometimes there's the illusion
that I could be white,
that I could pass, which I
don't think I've ever passed,
but also that I would want to.
And there's always a surprise when I say,
I would never want to be white actually.
And so I think there's something
along those lines, I think,
maybe that is troubling to the reviewers,
is actually even having the conversation
of whether you would want or
not want to change your race
produces a kind of tension,
because there are these assumptions
that these different people work with.
- That's great.
I wanna give just a
little time to the Q&A.
And I'm gonna read you a couple
of questions, is that okay?
So one says, thank you
for the wonderful talk.
I was wondering what
you make of the satire
in "Black No More" directed
against black activists
and intellectuals like W.E.B. Du Bois.
- Yeah.
I mean, Schuyler is a
great figure in some ways.
I recommend the biography of
him written by Jeff Ferguson.
He's a conservative in certain ways,
and I think the leftist
politics of that time
kind of bothered him.
But I also think there's
an attempt to skewer
the pretensions of that,
of the Harlem Renaissance,
of that community at the time.
And of course, one of the
things he makes a lot of
that's a grist for his satirical mill
is that Du Bois and other
people in the Harlem Renaissance
were all very light-skinned.
Du Bois himself could have passed.
So there's a kind of a sense, I think,
that he also wants to show up the colorism
that's implicit in both the
black and the white community.
He's satirizing power
dynamics and hierarchies
that are within both of those communities.
I mean, it's a pretty,
I think, short analysis
of a really, really fascinating text,
but that's what I would say about that.
- Okay, here's another one.
Thanks for a thought-provoking talk.
I totally agree that race, in quotes,
is experiences through time.
So you have one believer.
(laughs)
I wonder how you would read a scenario
of a white presenting person
being embedded in the community of color
and sticking a claim to
the identity of color.
Would that be a legit identity performance
in that connection?
Are you familiar with David
Henry Hwang's satire play
"Yellow Face" that was
made into a YouTube film?
- I am not familiar with it.
But it's interesting
because this sort of came up
in a conversation I had yesterday
when the trailer for the new
film of "Passing" came out.
There's been a lot of conversation
about whether the two
actresses cast in the film
could themselves pass as white.
And there's a lot, I mean,
one of the kind of tropes
of passing for the black community is that
if you see someone who's passing,
you've got their number, you
could identify them as black.
And so there are many people who say,
well, the idea that one of
these or both of these women
could pass as white means
that they could pass as white
to other white people, right?
But the reason this came up is because
Rebecca Hall, the director
of the film, is herself,
herself has black in the family, right?
It turns out that her
grandfather was black.
But no one in the family had registered
or identified as black for her whole life.
So she grew up as a white
passing black person
but with no sense of being black.
And she's an actress herself.
And so I wondered why she
didn't star in the film.
And I think even though she, I think,
would've been a better casting,
because she looks like she could be white
and so you might believe
it, she wouldn't be as good
because she doesn't have the
experience of being black,
which is again this kind
of cultural experience.
So I don't know, I don't
think a white person
living in a black community
or a person who's white identifying
or who has no blackness in their family
or in their community
and who just embeds in a black community
could be said to have
experience blackness, no.
But they are having a different experience
than a lot of white people, for sure.
But you have to understand
that what you describe
in this question is very
common, it's the South.
I mean, there are a lot of,
there's a lot of co-presence
of black and white people
in the South but it's still
an incredibly segregated
and racially divided community.
So I don't think that experience is simply
about being present
within a black community.
And I think that staking that identity
is very much akin to the kinds
of appropriative gestures
that I was talking about
in some of these texts,
where the desire to belong,
the sense, oh, it's just allophilia,
I just prefer black people and so on,
that's fine and good if you
wanna live your life that way.
But you can't then say,
I am there for black,
that's not how it works unfortunately.
- That is a beautiful
line on which to end.
Okay, Tina, I'll give you (audio warps).
- I was just gonna quickly
add just a couple of things.
I agree with everything.
But I would say maybe
two additional things.
One is that, just very
much, as in the talk,
I think one experience of racialization
is exactly the sense of not being able
to leave when you want to.
And that's one of the things
that distinguishes the,
being, I forget, a
white identifying person
who is living a black life,
is that, as in those fictional stories,
when that person wants to stop, they can.
And that's a critical part of, I think,
the black experience or
racialized experience
for many people, is that escape hatch.
There is no escape hatch.
The one other thing I would
say about that is that,
is that, I think, to take them,
all these sense of time and expand it
over a longer span, I think, to take,
I hate to utter her name,
but to take to the racial,
those all example, I think
she had mixed race children
who were black and she was
welcomed into the black community
not as a black person, but
as a black family member.
And over a couple generations,
the whiteness as such would disappear.
But to demand that the black time
peg itself to a lifetime,
I think that's just not how that works,
Yeah.
- Yeah, it tries to
short circuit something
that is actually, it's not
just days and weeks and months,
it's years and decades and generations.
I'm seeing some other
questions that I think I can
dispatch relatively quickly
if we have some time.
So there's some questions
about whether plays or films
that have to do with people
pretending to be Jewish
or pretending to be a
Nazi would be included.
There are some amazing race transformation
in the kind of speculative fiction sense,
tales about becoming Jewish.
There's a kind of
horrifically anti-Semitic play
that I almost considered,
but I wanted to limit this
to the question of black
and white transformation
because it is so prevalent
and because there are so many texts.
It was a way to narrow my scope somewhat.
And also, I think that
the dynamics of religious
quasi-ethnic transformation are different
than racial transformation
in the American sense.
And I'm asked if "BlacKkKlansman"
was a text I considered.
I did not, because that's
simply a change of voice
and it happens over the phone.
The same happens in "Sorry To
Bother You" by Boots Riley,
where it doesn't have the
science fictional gimmick.
And the memoirs that I looked at,
the non-fiction accounts that I looked at
all use some version
of some kind of science
to try to transform themselves.
One of the text that I almost
looked at was "Tropic Thunder"
because Robert Downey Jr.'s character
is said to have undergone
pigment augmentation,
which is similar to the
tanning pills in "Soul Man",
but it's such a brief
moment of transformation
and he basically appears as
black throughout the movie
and so it's closer in effect
to black face or minstrelsy
than it is to a race
transformation text as such.
Does the assumption of race
that it is a social construct
suggest that it is a caste system?
I think that there are many people
who are interested in
this idea, in sociology.
And we had this recent
book called "Caste".
What's her name?
Wilkerson, I wanna say.
But I read a review of that
book that put it into context.
It's in the Boston Review
and it's an excellent review
because it sort of pulls
apart some of the assumptions
and also talks about the difficulty
and perhaps the vagueness or fuzziness
of applying a system of caste,
which is kind of external to
the US, onto the US context.
So I would hesitate to follow from that.
I also don't think we need caste
to understand how race works.
We got a lot of analysis of how race works
as a social construct in the
history of American theory
and sociology.
And then finally, there's a question here,
well, there's two questions.
There's one about teaching these texts
and there's also one about
journeying, I don't think I
understand this one actually.
- I think the last
question is asking about,
no, I have to read it again too.
Go ahead.
- Sorry, sorry.
Yes, so it says, would it be fair
to include the going native or
white savior genre into this?
And I do think that there's,
those kinds of texts
do fall into the race
transformation as morality tale
subsection or exhibit of my circus.
But I think, again, the willful
transformation of the self
as opposed to moving into
a community to save it
or going native in the kind
of anthropological mode
are slightly distinct.
They have similar impulses
behind them, I do think,
but I would, again, by
trying to sort of work
with the very specific
idea of transformation,
of actually physical
transformation in these texts,
I'm trying to get it specifically
the way that this genre
produces its own aesthetics,
specifically the topsy-turviness,
the satirical tone, the immediacy,
the violence of the slapstick,
and also the sense of reversibility
or being able to go back if you can,
as Tina was pointing out.
So I was interested in, less in embedding
than in transforming.
Okay, so the final question I'll take
is about teaching these texts.
And so I've taught "Black
No More", "Get Out",
and a bit of the Robert Gilbert Wells's
"Anthropology Applied to
the White Man and Negro."
I've not taught the, any of the
white authored texts before.
I was considering teaching "The Menace"
in juxtaposition with "Black No More",
because they have so much in common,
including the mechanism
of the transformation.
And they were published
around the same time.
It provides, again, a very
instructive juxtaposition,
like the one I tried to
give you in the script
for "Watermelon Man"
versus the actual direction
that Melvin Van Peebles gave.
But it's difficult.
I mean, when I've taught
black science fiction before,
I've taught Bradbury and I've taught Poe
as ways of uncovering what Morrison calls
the kind of Africanus
presence in their works.
And I've taught a little
bit of Lovecraft as well
to show what it is that black
science fiction writers,
in some ways are, writing against
and what they're working with
in terms of a shared social set
of assumptions and stereotypes.
But it is difficult to teach
Ray Bradbury to undergraduates
in a science fiction course, who,
many of them have read
Bradbury and love Bradbury,
and for me to point out that actually
the story is incredibly racist.
And so I think it's useful,
and I don't believe in
canceling these authors.
I believe that it's useful to teach them
precisely with an attention
to where they fall short
and to where they reflect
the ideology of their time
and the racism that still exists.
This is how racism kind
of perpetuates itself,
is through the culture,
through the texts we read,
through the things we watch.
And so even when it's black
directors or black authors,
everyone is kind of participating
in this machine of etiology production.
Understanding how that works
is incredibly useful for students.
And so simply not reading
it is not gonna help
once they leave the classroom
and enter a post-Trump world,
where discarding Haitian refugees.
It's silly, I think, to pretend
that racism doesn't exist
and in the text that we
read and to banish all texts
that don't conform to our own politics
when actually we have to learn
it in order to counter it.
- Beautiful.
I'm gonna suspend here.
I know there's a lot more to talk about,
but thank you for taking us for a tour
through this difficult material
from the other side or the other sides.
Really appreciate it.
Again, lots of applause.
Congratulations and thank you.
- Thank you so much for having me.
And have a good evening, everyone.